las heridas de una noche de lluvias
torrenciales y vientos huracanados
todavía se ven en central park nueva
york
aida ya no es un huracán pero convertido
en ciclón post-tropical golpeó con
dureza el noreste de eeuu
nueva york- registró 8 centímetros de
agua en sólo una hora un máximo
histórico desde que se tienen registros
rompimos un récord hace dos semanas
ahora fue otro récord son lluvias que
nunca antes habíamos visto no podríamos
tener un mayor llamado de atención
el precio pagado por algunos
neoyorquinos ha sido horrible y trágica
de hecho se perdieron varias vidas al
llenarse de aguas sótanos de usados como
viviendas normalmente más baratas y
habitadas por personas con pocos
recursos
las escenas en el metro fueron
igualmente asombrosas y las violentas
inundaciones obligaron a suspender el
servicio
el presidente joe biden prometió ayuda
para la región y un plan para renovar
las infraestructuras
en estos días el huracán y los incendios
en el oeste y las inundaciones sin
precedentes en nueva york y nueva jersey
nader mind estas tormentas extremas son
otro recordatorio de que la crisis
climática está aquí debemos estar mejor
preparados necesitamos actuar zürcher de
varias voces se levantaron para criticar
la falta de preparación frente a la
llegada de las tormentas que ya habían
provocado graves daños a su paso por
luisiana y misisipí
se prevé que aida se disuelva durante
los próximos días pero la temporada de
huracanes todavía no ha terminado